Gabrielle Union is suing B et for breach
of contract
the actress stars on the network's hit
drama being Mary Jane I will never
settle for anything less than what I
want and what I deserve
et obtained Gabrielle's complaint in it
her lawyer claims the network wants to
shoot 20 episodes of the series
back-to-back versus what they allegedly
agreed upon which is no more than 13
episodes per season gabrielle alleges
the network is trying to fraudulently
extend the term of our contract money
seems to be a factor here the star was
set to get a raise between seasons she'd
make a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars per episode for season four than
a hundred and sixty-five thousand
dollars per app in season five but if
they film it all at one time that
increase doesn't come as quickly the
star is seeking at least 1 million
dollars in damages and wants her
contract to be amended so that there
will always be a maximum of 13 episodes
a season ET got this comment from
Gabrielle's lawyer we filed this lawsuit
because of BET's outrageous conduct
toward its number one star on its
highest-rated show and B et released
this statement to ET quote while we hold
Gabrielle Union in the highest esteem we
feel strongly that we are contractually
well within our rights and are committed
to reaching a swift and positive
resolution in this matter
you